there's a little secret the oil industry
has been trying to keep away from you
but we're going to try to expose it here
today this is a dangerous video you'll
see why let me tell you why because the
oil and gas industry is a$7 trillion
doll industry there's so many people
that have their hands in them making
money like guys we can't tell everybody
that there's another way that Finland
just did something they save power and
energy for their consumers by 75% we
can't have the rest of the world to know
about this because what if all of a
sudden this goes from a$7 trillion
industry to $1.8 trillion we cannot do
that in that industry The Source they're
worried about is nuclear energy nuclear
plant so what they do is they hire
lobbyist $124 million in 2022 and
nuclear only spent $1.56 million so they
got a lot of powerful people protecting
them and they'll come out and say things
like this nuclear plan what do you think
about when you think about the world
word nuclear explosion World War III
security people dying radiation this is
horrible this is why what happened to
Fukushima and Chernobyl this is why we
have to protect the people but then if
you think about the oil industry if it
does get dis disrupted what region of
the world would get plummeted the Middle
East it's not as if it is already
chaotic Saudi Arabia relies on oil you
take that out would the Middle East get
even more chaotic would some of the
powerful people in us that are in the
oil industry get more chaotic that's
pretty scary so they obviously have more
leverage but let me tell you what just
happened in Finland the newest nuclear
reactor in Europe and the biggest by
capacity started produ electricity in
Finland earlier this year oril luo 3
which has completed test production and
is now ready regularly producing
electricity is expected to account for
30% of finland's power generation the
plant operator TVO says after the
startup of Ula 3 power prices in Finland
ready saw a
75% plunge between December 2022 and
April of 2023 it's expected to produce
electricity for the next 60 years you
think the people in the oil industry
want to know this no you know what we're
going to do today we're going to
overcome all the objections they give us
accidents security cost sustainability
and then we're going to show you a wall
they built concrete wall at this nuclear
plant and they got this jet to fly into
it explosion to see how protected these
places are and you'll be able to be the
judge of that yourself but having said
that we're going to talk about this
crazy topic of nuclear energy
[Music]
today okay so if you get value out of
this video give it a Thumbs Up And
subscribe to the channel let's get right
into it nuclear is cheaper and cleaner
take a look at the CO2 emissions avoided
by the US power industry according to
the US Department of energy you would
look at nuclear all the way to the left
cleanest then it's wind then it's hydrop
power then it's solar then it's
geothermal but if this is the case why
do we not get more plants and more
people talking about building this
there's got to be a reason for this
let's talk about it so when you think
about capacity factor which is the
electrical energy output over a given
period of time a plant with a capacity
factor of 100% means it's producing
power all the time what plant do you
think has the highest capacity Factor
I'm assuming you took the guess and it's
the right guess ready take a look at
this nuclear number one
92.7% then it's geothermal then it's
natural gas then it's other gas then
it's other biomass then it's wood coal
hydroelectric then it's wind solar solar
natural gas internal combustion natural
gas Steam turb then it's petroleum which
by the way is 13.2% guess which one we
use the most in America that one right
there petroleum then it's natural gas
turbine then it's pump storage battery
then you can look at the other two take
a look at this chart on the next page
what America uses the most the number
one most use of energy in America we use
is petroleum then natural gas then
renewable energy which is solar and wind
then coal then last place nuclear
electric power only 8% of the time let's
unpack to to see how much money the
government spends in regards to energy
in fossil renewable and nuclear when you
look at fossil fuel the government
spends the most money on fossil fuel
which accounts for about 60% of his
total energy spending the majority of
the spending goes to support the
production and transportation of oil and
gas the key word there is what goes to
support the production the production
they're producing actual for
transportation of oil and gas producing
not testing renewable energy the US
government spends about 22% of its total
spending on this this money is used to
support the development
and deployment of renewable energy
Technologies such as solar wind and
biomass which again we see a lot of that
across the country but look at nuclear
energy the US government spends about
18% of its total energy on this this
money is used to support the
construction and operation of nuclear
plants construction and operation of
nuclear plants we don't know how much of
it is R&D how much of it is actually
doing the work so when you unpack that
here's what you'll notice the money
allocated towards a nuclear energy is
spent on the following ways number one
R&D the US Department of energy funds
research and development on new nuclear
technologies such as smaller modular
reactors and advanced nuclear fuel
Cycles which is great we need to Conant
be do an R&D number two licensing and
regulation the doe and the nuclear
regulatory commissions NRC are
responsible for licensing and regulating
nuclear power plants this includes
activities such as reviewing plan
designs conducting safety inspections
and issuing operating licenses again
find sometimes licenses they can be
holding back and they delay given it to
but we need to do that as well three
waste disposal the doe is responsible
for managing the Disposable high level
nuclear waste this includes activities
such as developing waste disposal
Technologies conducting research on the
waste disposal sites and managing waste
storage facilities again we need that
and last but not least security the doe
and the Department of Homeland Security
are responsible for the security at
nuclear power plans this includes
activities such as conducting security
assessments providing security training
and responding to security threats so
now let's go a little bit deeper about
nuclear power in the US the US is the
world's largest producer of nuclear
power accounting for more than 30% of
worldwide nuclear generation of
electricity the country's nuclear
reactor produce 843 kilowatt per hour in
2019 that's about 19% of total electric
output so I want to show you these two
charts in order for a reason because
something happened in 1986 take a look
at this nuclear energy production the
nation's leading non-fossil fuel energy
since 1984 has remained flat for the two
decades solar and wind energy are
growing so if you look at this to the
right you'll notice pink is nuclear look
how it was skyrocketing but it stayed
flat for two then look at how solar and
wind has gone up solar is green all the
way to the right and purple is wind all
the way to the right and then you'll see
everything else is kind of flat nuclear
was flat but why did it slow down all of
a sudden this next chart I want you to
look at this one shows the operable
nuclear power capacity the more plants
we build the more power we have and if
you notice this chart what question
would you ask looking at this chart
maybe the question is why did it all of
a sudden stop in 1986 well because in
April of 26 1986 is where the Chernobyl
disaster happened in Ukrainian SSR this
is on the border of Belarusian SSR again
in the Soviet Union it is one of only
two nuclear energy accidents rated at
seven the maximum severity on the
international nuclear event scale the
other being the 2011 Fukushima nuclear
accident in Japan the initial response
and subsequent migration effort involved
more than 500,000 Personnel cost an
estimated 18 billion rubles roughly $68
million in 2019 money and this scared
the hell out of everybody and say wait a
minute pump your brakes this is pretty
dangerous we don't want to touch this
and then it slow down now watch this in
the US when you look at nuclear plants
here's what you'll notice we have 92
reactors 53 plants 28 States roughly
475,000 well-paying sustainable direct
and indirect jobs in the nuclear
industry 93% capacity factor in the US
for nuclear plants as of 2021 I can give
you a bunch of different data that
validates this is the direction we ought
to go but there are some concerns now
watch when did we build a lot of these
plants what are the dates here's what it
shows so this list shows the last 35
that have been built if you notice most
of them were built in the 80s and the
'90s Clinton Power Station units 1 and 2
8991 Grand Golf Nuclear Station 89
Kataba Nuclear Station units 1 and
28991 Edwin ihatch nuclear plant unit 1
and two 89 and 90 Perry Nuclear Power
Plant 87 and then again you can go
through list 8589 8389 82 2014 20 2016
Texas 2016 then there's one that's in
the projects right now then there's a
couple right now that's in the process
in 2023 but you notice we've kind of
slow down after that because there was a
major concern of what could possibly
happen meanwhile investment in two areas
wind and solar has skyrocketed take a
look at this chart here from 2010 what
do you notice look look at solar
installations in us look at the utility
blue yellow non-residential blue
residential even if you go on this next
chart here for wind investment us go
from 1986 Chernobyl happens look what
happens all of a sudden this drops a
little bit then next thing you know all
we're doing is making investment and
then from 2010 it's skyrockets all the
way up to where it's at today wind
technology the US Department of energy
has allocated $132 million in fiscal
year 2023 funds for wind energy
Technologies and by the way you would
think maybe the US government is
interested and wanting to find out a
little bit more about this we take a
look at this in 2021 under Biden $480
billion of stimulus spending was
available for clean energy of which only
8.8 billion went towards nuclear energy
some of you may be watching and saying
Pat I'm not trying to get into the
nuclear business why are we doing this
video do you want to get into the saving
business because this could be applying
to you your family may be interested in
this your mom your your dad your wife
your husband people may be interested in
this take a look at this household
electricity prices worldwide in
September of 2022 this is last year
Denmark is the highest you think people
in Denmark won that to be lower how
about Italy how about Germany how about
Belgium how about Lithuania how about
Netherlands Finland just dropped because
this is reported in September they
launched that in November it dropped 75%
2 months after this report comes out
then you got UK so Finland was one of
the most expensive it's now one of the
lowest if not the lowest Spain Japan
Peru Rwanda France and then it's us us
is one of the top 8% most expensive
electricity in the world would we want
to see that be slightly less now the way
I work is in business in sales is you
choose all the top objections and you
figure out a way to overcome every
single objection we've done that we got
five objections for you the arguments
against nuclear energy first one is
nuclear waste second one is accidents
third one is security fourth one is cost
and last one is sustainability let's
start off with nuclear waste nuclear
power plants produce radioactive waste
which can be dangerous to human health
and the environment the counter to that
is used nuclear fuel rods are stored
safely and securely at reactor and
storage sites around the country either
in enclosed or steel line concrete pools
filled with water or in steel reinforced
concrete containers the US nuclear
Regulatory Commission has determined
that it is technically feasible to
continue to store used nuclear fuel
safely at Power Plant sites or
Consolidated interim storage facilities
for an indefinite period second
objection the accidents do we want
another accident like this to happen so
nuclear power plants are susceptible to
accidents which can have catastrophic
consequences the Chernobyl disaster in
1986 you know how many people died 31 31
too many but it's 31 it's not 15,000
it's not 5,000 it's 31 the Fukushima 201
how many people you think died in 2011
one person by the way according to
OurWorld IND dat. org only one death has
been attributed to the disaster this
includes both the direct impact of the
accident cuz some people say what about
radiation no this is both the direct
impact and the radiation exposure that
followed however it's estimated that
several thousands died indirectly from
the stress and disruption of evacuation
now non-fatal injuries you got six with
cancer or leukemia 37 with physical
injuries two workers taken to the
hospital with radi a Burns again one is
too many but when you hear about this
number you think about it was so bad
that so many tens of thousands of people
died from it they did not however let's
counter it in the US nuclear power
plants are constructed in such a way
that they are essentially invulnerable
to external assault even by a hijacked
aircraft the reactor building is made of
reinforced concrete and the reactor
vessel holding the fuel is made of steel
more than a foot thick furthermore the
fuel itself is encased in a solid metal
alloy that is difficult to Bridge all
the equipment and the piping are
ruggedly constructed and any equipment
not located in the reactor building is
housed in areas that are also strongly
built to give you an idea how tough the
material is Sandy National Laboratories
in 1988 crashed an F4 Phantom jet into
the same sort of reinforced concrete
that is used to construct nuclear power
plants the result the jet was destroyed
into millions of pieces and the concrete
was more or less fine the worst scar was
less than 2 and 1/2 in deep and in 2002
the Electric Power Research Institute
epri undertook an advanced computer
modeling study to determine if nuclear
power plants could withstand the impact
of an aircraft crash similar to the
terrorist attacks on September 11 2001
the Boing 767 was selected as the crash
aircraft in the study because it weighs
more substantial than almost all
commercial jet airliners flown in the US
the study concluded that none of the
parts of the Boeing 767 including the
engine Fus LOD wings or even jet fuel
could enter the containment building or
any other sensitive areas like the used
fuel storage pool this means that in the
ultimate catastrophic event an airline
crash or missile strike a nuclear plant
would not leak radiation next is
security what if all of a sudden
somebody you know terrorists want to
attack it and you know they target it
based on from the top they blow it up
well here's a counter most US nuclear
power plants are surrounded by large
rural areas making it relatively simple
to detect Intruders all of them are
surrounded by Outer Perimeter fences
equipped with sensors the first stage of
security is the owner controlled area
since a nation's nuclear plant went on
high alert after 9911 the security in
these fenced external areas has been
augmented by increased patrols and
Tighter access to the site the second
stage of security which is protected
area around Plant buildings is
surrounded by double fences and aess
strictly limited the third stage is
vital area of containment building which
is heavily guarded and sealed off to all
but those with specific access
authorization nuclear power plant
security plans have always been
formulated to secure the facility
against well-armed violent and possibly
suicidal Shooters worst case scenarios
have planned for also include vehicle
entering and delivering explosives as
events unfold around the world security
planners adjust accordingly employees
are also scrutinized background
investigators and personal evaluation
systems are part of any nuclear power
plants Safety and Security planning
plant personnel must be deemed fit for
Duty before they are allowed access to
the protected area their psychological
and physical conditions are constantly
monitored and they are randomly tested
for drug or alcohol use cost this one's
actually a very valid concern because
it's not cheap nuclear power plants are
very expensive to build making them less
cost competitive than solar and wind
power counter nuclear fuel is extremely
dense it's about 1 million times greater
than that of other traditional energy
sources and because of is the amount of
used nuclear fuel is not as big as you
might think all of the used nuclear fuel
produced by the US nuclear energy
industry over the last 60 years could
fit on a football field at a depth of
less than 10 yards that waste can also
be reprocessed and recycle although the
US does not currently do this however
some Advanced reactors designed being
developed could operate on used Fuel and
by the way the oil people win in this
specific argument would cost because the
average power plant nuclear power plant
takes around 4 to9 billion to build and
the operating cost every year is roughly
$150 to $200 million great now you have
it now going make money what are you
going to do now who are you going to
sell us to now what kind of money you
going to make if they can make the
incentive for it that high then it's a
formidable industry to be a part of if
it's just savings they still have to
figure out a way to make money so that's
where Oil wins to attract the
capitalists that are willing to do this
to make the money that's why capitalism
Works unless if government does it and
ask you and I the taxpayer to pay for it
and say look whether you're like it or
not you got to do it then that's a
different story and last but not least
sustainability nuclear power is not a
sustainable form of energy as the
uranium used in nuclear fuel is a finite
resource once uranium reserves are
depleted nuclear power will no longer be
a viable options that's what the
argument is the counter a typical 1,000
megawatt nuclear facility in the US
needs a little more than 1 square mile
to operate Nei says wind farms require
360 times more land area to produce the
same amount of electricity and solar
photovoltaic plants require 75 times
more space to put in perspective you
would need more than 3 million solar
plans to produ produce the same amount
of power as a typical commercial reactor
or more than 430 wind turbines capacity
Factor not included so the US Department
of energy made this chart which is
actually pretty good it says how much
power does a nuclear reactor produce the
equivalent of
3.125 million PV panel solar panels or
431 utility scale wind turbines or 100
million LED bulbs or roughly 1.3 million
horses or 2,000 Corvette z6s you want
more perspective take a look at this one
here that one uranium pellet you're
looking at that looks like a female hand
that that one lady is holding an inch
tall is the same as 17,000 cubic feet of
natural gas 120 gallons of oil and a ton
of coal that's why people are talking
about we may want to consider going to
nuclear energy so look there's a couple
thoughts of me when I'm thinking about
this one is my logical one is my
skeptical this The Logical thought is
okay they don't want to do this because
of safety security cost they're making
some investment but but not yet you know
maybe it's not that advanced yet
Chernobyl happened they're scared we
don't want to be the next one that
explodes and we're going to have to put
up with there no president want a
nuclear plant explosion under your watch
you're not going to get reelected and
you're going to have to deal with this
so people may be not doing it because of
that reason selfish reasons they're
afraid of what media is going to say but
let me give you the other side so
there's many people worldwide right now
that are making money young 20- year
olds 18 year old 16y old kids that reach
out to influenc and they said they'll
say let me make your short clips and
they'll message people and say we'll
make your short re like value tainment
style or such and such style or this
person style and we're going to make you
get millions of views and oh my God
that's great how do you do it well we
take a lot of time but it's 25 bucks a
real you're like okay no problem go
ahead here you go and the next thing you
know there's an app on AI you know what
it does you put a two-hour podcast a
three-hour podcast in it this software
independently spits out the top 10 most
viral Clips to go viral put the captions
puts the face does all the editing and
the description on what to put in it so
you literally copy paste upload the
video boom it goes out and AI already
told you this is the most likely video
to go viral wait what just happened
there all these other guys that are
making doing this app that they don't
want anybody else to know and they're
doing this for 20 other people they're
making 20 30 grand a month do you think
they want the talent to know that this
technology exists no they don't want
them to know that because you just cost
the money the same thing happens with
these oil people $7 trillion industry
work according to Forbes every 10 out of
22 billionaire on the Forbes 400 list
has ties to oil money you think they're
going to want that no they're not going
to want that but disruption happens in
many Industries I've been on it where
I've capitalized off of it I've been on
it where I took a hit from it in
insurance industry and other things I've
been a part of it's coming it's just a
matter of when but when you got
lobbyists for oil spending $125 million
in 2022 and you got only 1.56 million
for for nuclear energy it's very very
hard to beat those other lobbyists who
have much more money much more power
players with bigger Congressman contacts
and senators and presidents on their
speed dial to say no you can't do that
if you want money from me for your
campaign you cannot be supporting this
oh okay no no we weren't going to do
that do you see how that kind of works
out and by the way what I'm talking to
you right now a lot of this is on the
right side Republicans are not going to
be happy about this we're like what are
you talking about what you should be
talking about but disruption is coming
and when disruption is coming disruption
doesn't care if you're a Christian if
you're a Muslim if you're a republican
if you're a Democrat if you're a white
black Hispanic Middle Eastern Asian
college degree no college degree
disruption has this much sympathy for
you zero it did it to newspapers it did
it to TVs it did it to phones it's doing
it to computers it's done it in many
different Industries and it's not
stopping today even if you're a 7
trillion dollar industry having said
that if you enjoyed this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
if you want to watch two other videos
similar to this there's one called
vertical farm and if you've never
watched I'm fascinated by this industry
click you to watch it and if you want to
know some may say the most powerful man
in the oil industry number one most
powerful man in the oil industry MBS if
you don't know a lot about the Crown
Prince of Saudi Arabia NBS click here to
watch that take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye